Hi YouTube. I watched Pablo's video and I
really agree with him that it is slightly
different for CEOs and for doctors and lawyers,
I don't have very much to show you. But the
point that Pablo made about the fact that
making money should never be the only consideration.
Is something which even the greatest proponents
of capitalism, whether it's Adam Smith or
Wayne Brown made very clear. It's one thing
to make money while you are doing good for
your company, for your shareholders, for you
workers. And it's another to make money while
you are taking your company down the drain.
And this is really what's been happening.
Head CEOs getting bonuses while the companies
have been failing. We had John Thain redecorating
his office to the tune of a million dollars
while getting money from the tax payers to
bail out his company. This is virtually unacceptable.
And that where a moral commons, a code of
ethics needs to be ready. So the rules should
be, don't make money for yourselves in terms
of bonuses or redecorating your office or
anything like that while you are taking money
from the tax payers. And don't do it while
your company's going down the drain. I think
these are two very, very basic and ethical
rules that our CEOs need to follow. Otherwise
they are becoming the Marie Antoinettes of
the economic melt down. Remember when we read
about Marie Antoinette we used to talk of
love. What could she of possibly have said
that could of been seen? She wasn't getting
it, and many of modern CEOs aren't getting
it either.